explain that it's just opportunity cost
when I went to the grocery store I made
my list went to Costco bought all the
food came back unpacked it prepped it
cooked it boxed it put it in the fridge
and then every time I would eat it I
would clean my dishes all of that cost
me more time than just working as a
single guy oftentimes you have to cook
twice anyways by the sixth day the
chicken starts looking weird there's an
eyeball growing in there when I started
adding up the math the math didn't
pencil out to be fair I made more than
15 an hour so I knew that if I just
worked my leads for a day I would make
an extra Grand the message of that is do
the math just pencil out how long it
actually cost you how much does the
incremental cost compared to the
groceries that Delta if it's more than
25 of my income I shouldn't do it